Good morning, Hank, it's Sunday, it's News Day,
and that means it's time to get on board the Fail Boat,
with our intrepid captain, the Dread Fireball Wilson Roberts!
Hank, the Fail Boat is of course the puppy-captained, questionably seaworthy vessel
that we Nerdfighters use to transport ourselves around the various islands
of our archipelagic empire known as Nerdfighteria.
And that we also use to sail around the world learning about places currently experiencing World Suck.
Where to first, Skipper?
Willie says, "Aye Italia!"
Yes, Hank, first we're sailing the Fail Boat off to Italy,
and then...walking 8 miles inland to the Vatican,
where there has, lately, been quite a lot of hullabaloo over a certain quasi-bishop named Richard Williamson.
Hank, Richard Williamson is a crazy person, who, until recently, was excommunicated from the Catholic Church
on account of his being...crazy.
But then recently, Pope Benedict lifted the excommunication so that they could possibly begin the
process of rehabilitating this dude into the church so he could be a bishop again.
And a lot of people are upset about this because Richard Williamson
has repeatedly denied that the Holocaust involved the murder of 6 million Jews.
Now, thanks to the public outcry, Williamson has agreed to
"reconsider the historical evidence" of the Holocaust.
Which is like reconsidering the historic evidence that America had a president called Ronald Reagan.
So my guess is that Richard Williamson wants to be a bishop and so he's gonna say, okay,
there was a Holocaust, I'm sorry, and then maybe he's gonna get rehabilitated.
Which would be an error, because in addition to being a Holocaust denier,
Richard Williamson also has a lot of crazy beliefs.
Like, for instance, that women should not be allowed to go to college.
And perhaps most importantly,
Richard Williamson believes that women should not be allowed to wear pants.
Mister Williamson, when you try to take away our ladies' pants,
we here in Nerdfighteria take that quite personally.
Let me explain something to you, sir.
The book title '"Everything That Rises Must Converge" - in your pants?'
is funny.
The book title '"Everything that rises must converge" -
in the 19th century hoopskirt that was designed explicitly to limit your movement,
and thereby rob you of your power?'
is NOT funny.
And Richard Williamson, you, bishop or no, will NOT take away my in-your-pants-jokes.
Next stop on the Fail Boat...[gets interrupted by dog barking]
Oh, Captain Fireball, do you have something you wanna say to would-be-bishop Williamson?
[Dog barks]
Oh my, you tiny, white, fluffy pirates sure do have dirty mouths.
I wouldn't have used *those* words, but,
I do agree with the sentiment.
Where to next, oh Captain, my Captain?
[barks again] Very well then.
Full speed ahead to Australia!
In "Just because it's cold in *your* house doesn't mean Global Warming is a lie" News,
the deadliest wildfires in the history of Australia are currently raging in the south of the country.
So, Hank, for the last little while, it has been really hot and really dry and really windy in Australia,
like a 117 °Fahrenheit (47 °C) hot.
And these conditions have combined with what is, in at least some cases, apparent arson, to create
epicly horrible wildfires.
Hundreds of square miles of wilderness has burned, entire towns have been destroyed,
and many people have lost their lives.
Hank, you and I have many friends and fellow Nerdfighters,
who, when they're not wintering in Nerdfighteria, live in Southern Australia.
I know that we're both concerned about them,
and I hope that they know that our thoughts and prayers are with them.
Hank? This is yourself -
or possibly me wearing a you-costume in attempt to cheer up Australian Nerdfighters.
For Captain Fireball Roberts and the whole crew of the Fail Boat,
this is Hank Green saying "Best Wishes!"
Why yes, I DO also have a me-disguise.
By the way, thank you to the Nerdfighter who made this - but why did I get Kim Jong-Il's haircut?